alright guys I just saw Harry Potter
part 7 part 2 a few days ago and you can
see just got done to the bum review I
know he was my my opinion on the movie
my personal opinion of course you can't
talk about reports seven part two unless
you talk about the other parts I'll give
you just my real fast opinion of them I
can really sum them up in one word um
i-i've never been a huge Harry Potter
fan I don't hate them
I've just never gotten bad into is just
not really my thing um I sort of wanted
to like them I want to be more into him
but I think something about the weight
that the kid actors are and the dialogue
and the pacing I just felt I never felt
was that gripping but they're okay like
they're not horrible they're not bad I
just never got that into it a quick
run-through first movie look great cool
world could care less about the
characters second movie hey that's just
the first movie again a third movie
actually was almost pretty good because
it really can't restore was like to be a
teenager but boys are going gray um the
fourth movie I barely remember fifth
movie I barely remember
so did leave that big an impact movie
six I remember liking actually quite a
bit again though it was more by that
point it was sort of more the main kid
himself I sort of thought was a little
flat I just I couldn't get into him I
sort of thought I think Harry's the most
boring character which I don't think
it's good uh and then part 7 part one uh
while engaging I thought was just
unbelievably intense and just sort of
overly dark you know they all look
darker but they never seem that much
darker biasa than seven it's just like
you know and I liked if I had to
get out of the school it's like the
fugitive you know they it's sort of a
cheese and they're doing something a
little different but a pretty intense
and just not I could have used a few
smiles I mean come on so now we have
pipe seven part two uh and I I guess out
of all the movies this one for me is
probably my favorite because it was the
one
this seemed to go by the fastest and
that's always been a thing for me in the
Harry Potter movies they seemed so long
I mean kind of part 7 when they said you
know we have to find these pieces that
have Voldemort's soul how many of them
are there and I thought it is something
like 5 or 7 I'm like could you just make
it to God so this one this is the first
one where it's just like as it ended I
just looked at watch all my remedies
over already and it's like 2 hours so
it's not short but that's a sign that
the movies doing something good um it's
now the other thing about it is that
it's called Harry Potter the Deathly
Hallows part-2 when really it should
have been called The Return of the King
part 2 because that's really what I saw
this as I mean the fight scenes are like
scene for scene it's like Return of the
King I mean there's the giant rolls but
there's a giant spider if there's people
running through it's the same colors
it's kind of the same location it's just
it's very very similar but it's not bad
it's still pretty good action and and to
keep my interest and I'm happy to say
that after seven movie 7 full movies the
kid who plays Harry Potter has finally
gotten one emotion down and that is
pissed off when he looks pissed off
he looks really pissed off and you buy
it when he's pissed off the only
downside is that that's the alien again
that's the only emotion he's got in this
movie like there's a scene where he dips
his head in this magic toilet that shows
in the past and he sees all this stuff
about this main-care good just changes
everything I mean it changes the way you
look at everything it's this huge
gripping story it's actually much more
interesting than the other movies just
this one story is so fascinating and
what's the face he has I mean this whole
past is changed now what the PC has
pissed off I'm still pissed off that I'm
like Duke a tear or something I mean
look destroy I mean if I saw this
I'd be like holy crap my world's upside
down
so but the kids better and it's the
first time I was actually starting to
get into his character now after seven
eight films it's finally starting to get
there
I do also think that the movie should
the movies should not be called Harry
Potter they should be called her my me
cuz she's doing like all the work if you
ever known it's like she's the smart one
she's the one kicking ass
she's the one that knows all the spells
she's the one getting him out of the
situations it's like that it should have
been about her actually I really would
like these movies more of they're about
anybody by Harry Potter I think he is
such a bore um but again it it flowed
okay where I think the other films a lot
of times are just sort of formulate you
go to the school you meet everybody
again hello hello you have the Quidditch
match
yeah the hoos something's go and that
nobody should know about so everybody
knows about it and then little whispers
here and there and oh we got a
centimeter closer to figuring out what's
going on and that's sort of every movie
until part seven where they do something
different but that really dragged I mean
that was just like again you know
there's like five or seven parts of the
soul it's like so um in my I probably
like these movies a lot more if it was
just down to trick you could told this
in three films like what this week
I don't read the books come out and say
that everyone says the books are better
I trust them I do again I'm just not
into that so if they but these this
story as is told seems like it could
have been done in three books if the
movies are like the books which made
made they're totally different I don't
know I've heard various things but as is
um I I didn't love it but I didn't
dislike it either it's sort of it's on
the highest part of a yeah that that's
the best I can say for it so um not
being a super huge Harry Potter fan I'm
I'm glad I saw it that way
I don't think I've regret seeing any of
them but this one I sort of felt like I
obviously had the most stuff going on
and I could follow it the closest you
know there's still a ton of scenes where
I'm just I have asked my friends to wear
Harry Potter fans all right why did this
happen how did this a what lows in the
blah blah blah I will say the climax is
quick which they really build up a I
mean even my trailer
they really build up Harry Potter going
up against uh Voldemort
you know they build up and shooting the
lines and you know the movies built it
up it's over so quickly and I really
would have liked something a lot more
punch to it but there's so much action
in the rest of it really doesn't matter
so um again the whole I say but a very
high yeah
for me for Harry Potter fans and I went
I went with people who weren't fans and
people who were the people who were fan
seemed to really like it they so it was
pretty close to the books and let thou a
few things but that that just happens
people who weren't we're still confused
by a few things but liked it okay you
know enjoyed it so so it's probably a
solid bed that you're not gonna get too
many people are gonna hate this movie
all the problems I have with it you know
I sort of put in the bum review but
again you give them a little leeway
because it is quote-unquote children's
fantasy and you let that stuff slide
this is gonna be closed in a millisecond
but you know it's whatever it's fantasy
it's all good so um yeah that's really
about it I can't say I'm gonna miss
having these but we start around because
I was so sick of going to see him and
have to review him but none of them were
god-awful and none of them were
spectacular in my opinion I thought they
were all of just that there were decent
there okay um I know it's meant a lot to
like a big generation of people that's
cool it's gotten a lot of kids in the
reading thank God I think that's
wonderful so I don't hate the Harry
Potter event franchise whatever at all I
like a lot of the stuff that's done it's
got a lot of people to fantasies so um
yeah that's pretty much my two cents I
guess I recommend it even people who
aren't fans you'll probably get
something out of it you know even it's
just a fun little adventure so that's
about it then I shall see you later